la disparition d'eric tabarly au large
du pays de galles le navigateur est
tombé à la mer un peu après minuit il
n'y a pratiquement plus d'espoir de le
retrouver vivant le gouvernement
français demande que les recherches se
poursuivent
reportages et réactions dans ce journal
nous nous retrouverons en direct de
nantes marc pajot la dea compagnon de la
première heure il avait que tabarly à
peu près en 73 le tour du monde sur pen
duick 6 les vins des célèbres hospices
de beaune serait trafic et contre la
réglementation européenne ces bourgogne
sont chaptaliser acidifier selon notre
confrère libération
le parcours sans faute de l'équipe de
france une équipe attaque en ce 3 but à
zéro la joie des supporteurs vernis
aujourd'hui par la mort de fernand
sastre qui était l'initiateur du mondial
madame monsieur bonsoir c'est en milieu
d'après midi que nous est parvenue
l'annnonce de la disparition en mer
d'eric tabarly au large du pays de
galles il n'y a pratiquement aucune
chance de retrouver vivant le navigateur
passer par dessus bord au cours de la
nuit dernière dans un instant nous
reviendrons sur les circonstances de
l'accident
à l'évidence l'émotion est grande elle
touche au coeur chacun d'entre nous eric
tabarly incarne l'image du marin
français et son nom est pour toujours
lié à celui des pen duick
ironie du sort c'est à bord du premier
de ces voiliers le pen du quincaillerie
tabarly est tombé à la mer la nuit
dernière luc basis à ces deux ce bateau
qui rique tabarly est tombé à la mer la
nuit dernière penduick 1 son premier
amour de navigateur eric tabarly aurait
chuté en allant changer de voile
ils revenaient des îles britanniques
avec un équipage de quatre personnes
il est la seule victime de cet accident
survenu au large du pays de galles à
environ 80 km des côtes de milford haven
les passagers du pen duick peu
expérimentés n'ont réussi à prévenir les
garde-côtes britanniques que tôt ce
matin avons été alertés à 7 heures ce
matin par un voilier de plaisance qui
avaient repéré une fusée de détresse
mais ça faisait plus de sept heures qui
recte à marly et est tombé dans la mer
la mer n'était pas très mauvaise ce
genre de bateau en tout cas le vent
était de force 5 orientée sud est
évidemment on peut considérer que
l'expérience de monsieur tabarly
compenser l'inexpérience de ses
passagers mais avec un accident comme
celui-là
ils n'ont pas su comment diriger le
bateau pour retrouver eric tabarly
une fois qu'ils étaient passés par
dessus bord personne n'a pu diriger le
bateau et ça c'est vraiment malheureux
si les britanniques ont abandonné leurs
recherches du côté français en revanche
la marine nationale a envoyé un breguet
atlantique un avion arrivé sur zone
il y a tout juste trois quarts d'heure
j'avais fait rien donné donc vers le
coucher du soleil vers 23 heures ça rien
donné on reprendra demain matin et est
ce que votre avis plus de 12 heures
après tombé dans l'eau il ya des chances
de le retrouver vivant
bah on est un peu pessimiste on pensera
mais tant que
tabarly a disparu il n'est pas considéré
comme mort on continue les recherches
quoi eric tabarly âgé de 66 ans officier
de marine à la retraite vivait dans le
finistère sur les bords de l'odet en
famille et aux côtés de son épouse et de
sa fille sur place et la consternation à
bénodet reportage olivier sio la
nouvelle a privé marin breton par
surprise tabarly leur tabarly est porté
disparu en mer pourtant cet après midi
sur le port de bénodet certains refusent
est encore d'y croire qu'ils espèrent
que les recherches en continu aux mages
désespère parce qu il ya de personnes
sont tombés à la mer et qui ont été
récupérés dans les deux bien supérieur
d'autant qu'elle est appelée dans l'eau
j'espère encore mais le hasard a voulu
que la nouvelle tombe au moment même où
à quelques kilomètres de là se déroulait
une course de voiliers bien sûr au fil
des années des régates bon nombre
d'équipages avait eu l'occasion de
rencontrer le skipper des pen duick
nous avons appris cette nouvelle en
course évènement a été très choqué à
bord du bateau et tabarly c'est un mythe
pour nous tous était notre père c'était
notre peuple notre dieu coin c'est l
ambassadeur de la voile française
je crois qu'il a porté haut le fanion et
il a démocratisé quand même là la voile
c'est grâce à lui si nous avons tant de
plaisanciers en france parce que il a
été l'exemple de tous les plaisanciers
en france mais la plupart de ceux qui
ont bien connu tabarly préféré se
réfugier dans le silence meilleur
hommage disait-il ou légendaires
caractère taciturne de leur ami eric
tabarly n'était pas homme à se confier
n'ya s'est penché ce marin d'exception
ne se liait pas facilement
pourtant ce soir chaque breton a le
sentiment d'avoir perdu l'un des siens
eric tabarly le plus célèbre navigateur
français a lancé la course au large
grâce notamment à sa victoire dans la
transat anglaise en solitaire en 64 à la
barre de pen duick ii depuis il avait
enchaîné les performances battu le
record mythique de la traversée de
l'atlantique
sa dernière victoire remontait tout
juste à octobre dernier quand il avait
gagné la route du café avec yves parlier
entre le havre et carthagène en colombie
christophe duchiron
il était dit qu'entre eric tabarly la
mer et les bateaux
il y aurait quelque chose d'une
indescriptible passion une passion forte
et silencieuse car si tabarly et mais le
bruit de la mer et le son du vent il
n'aimait pas les mots de peur peut-être
d'en dire un peu trop tabary le taiseux
avaro phrases toutes faites en formules
à l'emporte-pièce paradoxe jamais un
marin en france n'aura fait parler
autant que lui car tabarly était de ces
personnages que la légende un jour
s'approprie de leur vivant 1964 la
france du général de gaulle se découvre
un marin venait
tabarly a remporté l'oscar la transat
anglaise en solitaire tabarly le breton
arrive en tête à newport aux états unis
à la barre de pen duick 2 il a 33 ans un
français devance les anglais qui avaient
l'habitude de faire la loi sur les
océans la légion d'honneur pour le
capitaine de vaisseau tabarly
1976 douze ans après à bari récidive une
deuxième victoire dans la transat
anglaise à part cette fois de pen duick
6 tabarly premières stars de la voile
qui laisse en dit un peu plus tard les
champs elysées la voie du triomphe le
bain de foule du vainqueur il a 45 ans
et déjà on l'a affublé d'un surnom pipés
tout au long de sa carrière pp superstar
aura gagné sur tous les océans du monde
et tout au long de sa carrière
pp or à former des mares un coupon de
kersauson cola lamazou et bien d'autres
les enfants navigateur d'eric
je suis content de voir que en france on
a des bons marins je sais pas si je sais
pas si
c'est tout à cause de moi je pense pas
c'est peut-être une petite partie avant
deux mois
irie tabarly n'a pas été qu'un simple
vainqueur toute sa vie il a cherché à
améliorer inventé c'est lui qui
expérimente en premier les folles
c'est un panier sous les flotteurs qui
font se lever l'accord hors de l'eau
quand le bateau prend de la vitesse
c'était le début des années 80 le
trimaran paul ricard
cette idée majeure s'est concrétisée
aujourd'hui avec l'hydroptère un projet
mené par alain thébault initié par eric
tabarly tabarly qui barrait ce drôle
d'engin cet hiver encore
l'hydroptère c'est sans doute le futur
des multicoques c'est dire que le
sillage d'eric tabarly n'est pas près de
disparaître à 60,6 en octobre dernier
eric remporté la transat en double le
havre carthagène en compagnie d'yves
parlier un dernier trophée le dernier
baiser de pépé à la course en mer un
jour olivier de kersauson andy de tabari
qu'il était l'idole déroule aujourd'hui
lidoli partie versement de qu'elle
aimait tant
le monde du silence c'est au connue la
nouvelle de sa disparition a suscité de
nombreuses réactions le monde de la
voile et sous le choc témoignages des
navigateurs paul vatine et alain gautier
pour moi il était du domaine du sacré on
sait qu'il a formé une légion de
navigateurs célèbre c'est quelqu'un qui
a mis la voile au niveau du grand public
il a navigué il a bataillé avec tous les
et soeurs du monde c'était un combattant
mais en même temps très humble très
respectueux très très respectueux
d'éléments nos marins très respectueux
de la sécurité un champion populaire
très populaire en france
la voile eric tabarly c'est celui qui a
mis là qui a démocratisé quelque part la
voile donc pour moi eric ne mord pas de
cette façon là c'est difficilement
imaginable comme c'était difficilement
humaniser imaginable de voir senna s'est
tapé un mur a alors qu'on le pensait
indestructible c'est comme ça le ça fait
partie des choses de la vie
et puis ce communiqué de lionel jospin
eric tabarly était devenue un symbole et
une référence ça disait la disparition
nous bouleverse
le premier ministre a ajouté qu'eric
tabarly est allé au bout de sa passion
et de sa volonté
pour le président de la république
jacques chirac se dit très inquiet il a
demandé à être tenu au courant heure par
heure du déroulement des recherches
revenons à présent sur les circonstances
exactes de l'accident
il était un peu plus de minuit lorsque
eric tabarly est tombé à la mer
apparemment il ne portait pas de gilet
de sauvetage l'eau et hermance degré et
si l'équipage a immédiatement lancé une
bouée de sauvetage
il n'a pu voir dans l'obscurité si eric
tabarly a pu s'en saisir arnaud goûter
olivier robert
selon les premiers éléments de l'enquète
tout l'équipage soit quatre personnes se
trouvaient sur le pont au moment de
l'accident
eric tabarly change est une voile
lorsqu'il est tombé par dessus bord
une bouée lui a été lancé un modèle
comme celui ci que l'on retrouve sur
tous les voiliers qui s'éloigne à plus
de 20 milles des côtes
on passe le corps à l'intérieur de sa
autour de la taille ensuite le canton
jette le feu retournement à l'eau il
vient c'est qu'il oeuvrait comme ceux ci
et c'est clair automatiquement
voilà le principe le feu de retournement
peut donc être vue de l'eau ou du bateau
mais avec un vent de force 5 tout dépend
avec quelle rapidité les membres de
l'équipage jet labour et quelques
secondes de trop et elle devient
inaccessible en mer tous les rescapés
doivent la vie à leurs équipements
notamment ses vestes de car qui
contiennent des réserves de flottabilité
il considérait que lui-même avait
tellement de métier tellement d'habilité
à se mouvoir sur un pont que il n'avait
pas besoin de s'amarrer que pour lui ça
mares aurait été une gêne eric tabarly
refusez donc ce petit clic ils repêchent
pourtant de nombreux marins pour qui la
vie compte plus que la liberté
ils nous rejoignent maintenant direct de
nantes marc pajot bonsoir êtes là des
compagnons de la première heure d'eric
tabarly je dirais qu'au moment de
l'accident tabarly convoyait simplement
un bateau il avait connu des mers bien
plus agité évidemment l'émotion et
peut-être même un peu d'incrédulité de
votre part oui c'est vrai que moi j'ai
eu la chance de découvrir de connaître
et que j'avais tout juste maintenant
quand on est parti sur ce premier course
autour du monde donc c'était pour moi
mon père mon maître en matière de course
au large donc aujourd'hui c'est un
vraiment on a du mal à parler à
l'imparfait parce que on le respectait
tous je crois qu'il a beaucoup beaucoup
beaucoup apporté tant en tant que marin
mais peut-être
encore plus en tant qu'homme parce que
c'était éric c'était ce rock comme on le
surnommait mais c'était aussi un homme
sincère un homme intègre un homme franc
donc toutes les qualités que l'on peut
trouver chez un marin mais c'est un
homme normal le pen duick de par sa
configuration est un bateau qui n'a pas
dû filière de sécurité c'est l'un de ces
dangers potentiels
oui alors je crois qu'il faut il faut
peut-être expliquer qu'aujourd'hui le
port de la brassière même sur un bateau
côtier est sans doute nécessaire
c'est vrai que ce penduick n'avait pas
de filière métier rick connaissait bien
son bateau c'était le bateau de son père
il le connaissait par coeur je crois
qu'il faut simplement respecter la mer
dire on voit eric cette mère qui l'a
toujours aimé beaucoup respecter aussi
on va en reparler mais à moi encore
tabarly dit on ne portait pas de gilet
de sauvetage c'était son habitude trop
de conscience trop de routine qui font
perdre le sens du danger ou et peut-être
mais deux choses d'une part le harnais
de sécurité cette fameuse ce fameux
harnais que l'on clip sur le bateau et
d'autre part la brassière de sauvetage
dont claude à flottabilité
je crois qu'aujourd'hui c'est devenu
indispensable il faut même le répétez
pas simplement quand on part au large
mais simplement sur des régates côtières
franck les pays nordiques ont découvert
peut-être beaucoup plus tôt que ça
devient vraiment indispensable parce
qu'un simple petit accident et on parle
des risques aujourd'hui malheureusement
mais d'autres accidents ont eu lieu ces
années précédentes ce qu'eric tabarly
avait évoqué avec vous la peur de la mer
la peur de la mort oui eric tu parler
facilement de toutes ces choses là il y
effectivement il aimait par dessus tout
les bateaux il les connaissait bien
mais il n'avait pas peur d'en parler il
savait qu'on prenait des risques mais
pour lui il maîtrisait et
tout en respectant la mairie la maîtrise
est toujours il savait bien composer
avec elle toujours parfois savoir
ralentir savoir accélérer quand c'était
possible
donc c'est peut-être le destin tous les
cas je crois qu'on doit tous dire un
grand merci pour tout ce qu'il a fait
pour la pour la voile pour la pour la
france en général vous en parlait très
bien on dit sur cette personnalité que
c'était un homme rentré à trop verte'
peut-être solitaire c'était une fausse
réputation
oui et non puisque j'ai eu la chance de
passer trente quatre jours en tête à
tête en transat en double avec lui il
avait le mot juste et je crois que c'est
ça qui devient où tous les cas qui est
très important que ce soit sur un bateau
pour une manoeuvre vis-à-vis d'un
équipage ou vis-à-vis de la dureté de
l'épreuve physique c'est un athlète en
plus mais aussi ce mot juste fait
qu'aujourd'hui on le respecte tous qu'on
soit marins ou terriens cette justesse
des mots étaient importantes chez reed
un mois encore peut-être avant de
terminer marc pajot à un souvenir une
image qu'il vous reste comme par exemple
les équipes lors de la transat en double
je crois qu'il faut se souvenir des
risques chantant edith piaf par un pas
un beau coucher de soleil avec ses
copains autour de lui merci marc pajot
en marge de ces compétitions eric
tabarly s'étaient battus en 96 pour
empêcher le déménagement du musée de la
marine alors que jacques chirac envisagé
lui de récupérer le bâtiment pour
installer un musée des arts premiers
apparemment l'obstination du [ __ ] du
navigateur a payé stéphane haumant eyene
gicquel se sont rendus au musée de la
marine cet après midi eric tabarly aimer
la mer pour son immensité mais aussi
pour ses modèles réduits depuis quelques
années il avait pris la barre du comité
de soutien au musée de la marine
menacé d'expulsion du palais du
trocadéro ici sont exposés 17 min
maquette parfois centenaires parfois en
bois précieux
dans le domaine maritime finalement n'a
pas tellement d'occasions d'être fiers
et
là au moins on a peut-être le plus beau
musée du monde donc se fait ce serait
dommage de dole perdent ici jacques
chirac souhaitait installer un musée des
arts premiers
on dit que les rencontres entre le
président et le marin furent houleuse
pour l'instant c'est tabarly qui a gagné
la bataille le musée de la marine est
toujours au trocadéro et il devrait y
rester
les visiteurs qui déambulait cet après
midi dans les salles avait du mal à
croire à la disparition du navigateur
eric tabarly représente pour moi
l'évasion le courage un grand marin
une conviction une force morale une
force physique
c'est un grand temps que tout le monde
le connaît on sait ce qui place et c'est
un grand monsieur qui était pas évident
il avait l'air assez rugueuse d'abord
mais bon si c'est le bon sens paraît
étrange choix étrange tabarly
l'insubmersible a disparu on le croisait
souvent aux musées lieux de mémoire
les marins qui tu dois la mort
connaissent le prix du souvenir
et puis je vous propose de découvrir à
l'instant ces images qui nous
parviennent les premières images du pain
déduit que le voilier d'eric tabarly
c'est dans le petit port du pays de
galles au large duquel eric tabarly est
porté disparu
ses quatre compagnes ans sont sains et
saufs
le reste de l'actualité il ya une
quinzaine de jours nous évoquions la
sphère de château giscours ses vins de
bordeaux trafic est aujourd'hui notre
confrère libération révèle une nouvelle
fraude qui touche les célèbres hospices
de beaune
les producteurs auraient chaptaliser
acidifier les 22 l'année précédente
une pratique contraire à la
réglementation européenne mais tolérée
par l'administration française
les amateurs de vins apprécieront benoît
gadret thiery simonet chaque année c'est
un rituel
la vente aux enchères des vins des
hospices de beaune une véritable
institution en bourgogne
c'est dire si l'accusation de fraude
secoue tout le milieu viticole en 1997
les hospices aurait donc su créer
acidifier le vin pour pallier
l'insuffisance de qualité or la
réglementation prévoit que l'on peut sur
un même millésime soit chaptaliser
rajouter du sucre pour augmenter le
degré d'alcool soit acidifier pour
assurer une meilleure garde mais en
aucun cas faire les deux sur le même
vent il faut arrêter ce truc là ya pas
de scandale en bourgogne beau plus pour
les hospices de beaune péché - nick
ailleurs le président de l'association
des viticulteurs est en colère pour lui
la réglementation interdit de sucré
acidifier au même moment mais pas de le
faire en deux temps
question d'interprétation c'est pratique
très répandue en bourgogne sont même
déclarés à l'administration des
conventions dans les gisements
ces pics de sous terre et voilà ici
certificat taclé mardi 20 ici tous les
viticulteurs qui ont utilisé de l'acide
tartrique qui doit y avoir plus de 400
cette année avait eu le sentiment d'être
chaude il l'aurait pas fait et il est
vrai que l'administration tolère la
pratique elle vient même de solliciter
l'indulgence de la commission européenne
pour prendre en compte une spécificité
bourguignonne ce n'est pas un problème
de fraude ou d'escroquerie ya il faut
pas faire l'amalgamé entre toutes les
affaires simplement ce qu'on peut dire
c'est que les bourguignons un petit peu
anticipé une interprétation qui a été
demandé à la commission qui ne s'est pas
encore prononcée reste que le recours de
plus en plus systématique à ces
expédients et pas seulement les
mauvaises années inquiète certains
viticulteurs soucieux de préserver
l'image du bourgogne
le principe en lui-même d'acidifier
chaptaliser ne me choque pas à condition
ce soit exceptionnel pour des incidents
climatiques grave et que deuxièmement
que la loi n'autorise et d'une manière
année par année et non pas d'une aire
général allait finalement un vin
chaptaliser et acidifier ne peut nuire à
la santé car ces opérations se font à
partir d'éléments naturels en revanche
beaucoup considèrent que cela altère la
sensation gustative à nantes un
laboratoire unique au monde fait la
chasse aux fraudes alimentaires et des
sels de façon scientifique
les vins chaptaliser que nous venons
d'évoquer mais aussi les jus de fruits
coupés à l'eau ou encore les fausses
confiture cet institut acquis une
renommée internationale
romuald venant frédéric de la rue ici
les apparences sont trompeuses
les bouchons de champagne sautent
pourtant tout le monde est au travail
travail de fin limier même car ces
scientifiques font la chasse aux vrais
faux aliments et aux produits truqués
pur jus de fruits coupés halle aux vins
chaptaliser ou mélangé arômes qui n'ont
de naturel que le nom et même s'ils
gardent eux à vannes en fait d'origine
inconnue
cette fois des vins de méthode
champenoise sont passés au crible dans
ce laboratoire technologique unique au
monde
tout commence comme pour un bouilleur de
cru
en fait je fais une initiation de
l'alcool présent dans le vin est en fait
ça permettra une identification de
l'origine du vin le but de ces chimiste
faire parler les entrailles de n'importe
quelle substance ils ont une arme
secrète
cette machine infernale dont le labo
nantais détient le brevet mondial
un appareil de résonance magnétique
nucléaire pour aller au coeur des
molécules et molécules décortiqué pour
retrouver des empreintes la signature
concernant l'origine botanique et
géographique d'une plante ou d'un fruit
il est même possible de reconstituer le
processus de fabrication d'une boisson
ou d'un aliment sur ce vin par notre
analyse nous sommes allés à l'intérieur
des molécules du produit pour déterminer
de quelle plante provenait le sucre à
savoir est-ce que c'était du sucre de
raisin uniquement ou bien est-ce que du
sucre a été ajouté et ici nous avons pu
montrer que du sucre avait réellement
été ajoutés dans le produit est donc ce
vin il est il ait fraudé 20 frauder par
ajout de sucre de betterave fraude
encore pour remplacer de la vanille
naturelle à 20 mille francs le kilo par
sa copie de synthèse à 100 francs le
kilo fraude toujours pour faire passer
de l'huile de noisette pour de l'huile
d'olive 3 fois plus cher à chaque fois
une raison économique
ce sont en effet des raisons économiques
et souvent dans ces cas là cela traduit
un déséquilibre fort entre l'offre et la
demande qui peut être lié à des raisons
climatiques ou bien des guerres par
exemple la yougoslavie au début des
années 90 si une guerre pénurie de
framboises car la yougoslavie est le
principal fournisseur de framboise et
donc on a fraudé sur la framboise à ce
moment tout à fait on a fraudé sur la
framboise parlera ajout de sucre ou
mélanges d'autres fruits des arnaques
difficile à chiffrer mais dans certains
secteurs
près de 10% des produits alimentaires
seraient concernés
la course entre fraudeurs et
scientifique et lancé une course dont le
gagnant le perdant sera le cadet du
consommateur
l'actualité l'étranger avec cette
effroyable famine qui touche le soudan
une population exemple qui fait face à
la fois la malnutrition à la sécheresse
et la guerre civile qui oppose le nord
et le sud du pays eric mener elle a
marché
elle a marché jusqu'à l'épuisement comme
elle ils sont des milliers à converger
vers les centres de distribution des
organisations des d'international
victimes encore et toujours de la même
équation guère plus sécheresse égale
familles dans leurs villages du sud
soudan
la pluie n'est presque pas tombés
l'année dernière la guerre civile elle
n'a presque jamais cessé depuis 15 ans
elle oppose le gouvernement islamiste du
nord aux rebelles chrétiens et animistes
du sud dans un conflit à la fois
politique culturelle raciale même razia
enlèvements de jeunes filles enrôlement
forcé des garçons c'est le lot quotidien
dans les villages alors on fuit dans
cette région du bahr al ghazal 350 mille
personnes sont en danger de mort 30 %
des enfants sont malnutris
dans les centres ou par largage le
programme alimentaire mondial de l'onu
distribuer deux mille tonnes de
nourriture par mois il en faudrait trois
fois plus nul ne peut prédire si les
pluies seront cette année au rendez vous
caprices du ciel
quant aux caprices des hommes l'espoir
né d'un accord le mois dernier entre les
deux partis et des cieux il n'a même pas
été suivi dans ses cinémas où se
déroulent depuis dimanche dernier de
violents affrontements entre militaires
insurgés et forces loyalistes
l'évacuation des français a commencé à
bord d'un bateau sénégalais destination
de dakar une quarantaine de femmes
d'enfants et de personnes âgées ont pris
place hier la marée à gênés
l'embarquement de ressortissants
étrangers une partie de la communauté
française est actuellement regroupés au
centre culturel français de bissao
jacques chirac s'est entretenu
aujourd'hui à l'elysée avec le dirigeant
albanais du kosovo ibrahim rugova la
menace d'une intervention militaire se
précise si a indiqué le président de la
république l'agression des serbes se
poursuit un langage d'une extrême
fermeté alors que le temps effectuera
lundi prochain des manoeuvres aériennes
baptisé faucon déterminé comme son nom l
indique une démonstration de force qui
devrait faire pression
bernard lebrun un âne et quelques effets
personnels sauvées des ruines de leur
maison
c'est tout ce que ce couple emmène dans
son exode vers l'albanie
ni la pluie ni le brouillard pas plus
que la montagne ou la frontière minées
entre le kosovo et l'albanie n'arrête ce
flot de réfugiés
il serait de 13 à 20 mille selon les
sources désormais en lieu sûr mais en
situation de détresse
leur très pauvre cousin d'albanie
viennent bien à leur secours
mais eux-mêmes manquent de tout alors
pour la toute première fois depuis le
début de la crise un avion d' aide
humanitaire s'est enfin posé ce midi à
tirana tentes et rations de survie
médicaments vont être acheminées par
camion jusqu'à la frontière où se
trouvent les réfugiés côté militaire
rien ne bouge les f-16 américains
stationnés en italie sur les bases de
l'otan ne décolleront pas avant lundi
pour survoler l'albanie et la macédoine
dit on l'opération baptisée faucon
déterminée est censé impressionné le
pouvoir serbe de belgrade
côté diplomatique ce matin le leader des
albanais du kosovo ibrahim rugova a été
reçu avec les honneurs dus à un chef
d'état au palais de l'elysée un signe
qui ne trompe pas la france n'entend pas
que la tragédie bosniaque serait bien
qu'il ya une intervention brutale de la
part des serbes
une volonté en réalité de purification
ethnique à nouveau ce qui n'est pas
acceptable il le faut utiliser tous les
moyens de pression nécessaire et compris
les moyens militaires avant cela un
ultime rendez vous diplomatiques se
déroulera lundi à moscou où se rendre à
slobodan milosevic
boris eltsine tentera de le convaincre
d'ouvrir de vraies négociations avec les
albanais du kosovo retour en france avec
amiens cet après midi et quelques
milliers de manifestants dans le centre
de la ville contre le front national et
contre charles baur président de la
région de picardie élu grâce aux voix du
fn ambiance plutôt bon enfant
on était venu en famille quelques
personnalités dont l'actrice jane birkin
banderoles les drapeaux dossier lows
alliance de la droite et du front
national
et puis près de 500 personnes à mantes
la jolie ont manifesté dans le calme
pour demander que justice soit faite
après la mort dans des circonstances mal
élucidées de trois jeunes du quartier en
ils revendiquent eux les policiers
impliqués dans cette affaire soit jugée
cette semaine se tenait à paris un
colloque international consacré aux
problèmes de nutrition pendant la
grossesse à l'ordre du jour la prise de
poids chez les femmes enceintes un sujet
qui intrigue toutes les futures mamans
et sur lequel se sentant chez jean
daniel flaysakier pascal caron dans
quelques jours patricia fera les courses
avec alix si c'est le prénom qu'elle a
choisis pour le bébé qui devrait naître
fin juin pour l'instant il faut manger
pour deux mais en privilégiant certains
produits de fromage ou produit laitier
de poisson ça a un peu triché je suis
gourmande déjà en temps normal donc je
m'accorde le week-end des petits des
petits extras
pas question donc remis le dimanche de
faire une visite éclair à la pâtisserie
pour se jeter sur les gâteaux et sur les
gaz car la sage-femme veille pas
question pour les futures mères de
prendre plus de 10 à 12 kg en moyenne au
cours de la grossesse
une surveillance qui s'exerce jusqu'au
bout on sait que des fois la prise de
poids en fin de grossesse est plus
importante
écrire des baies lui grossi aussi
beaucoup plus de dix ans jusqu'à 50
grammes par jour enfin grand et tout
excès de poids peut compliquer
l'accouchement si rien est interdit il
faut savoir équilibrer son alimentation
et amel qui attend son troisième enfant
n'a pas tout bon de ce côté là sixième
mois de grossesse
verdict de la balance quand même
beaucoup ça fait déjà deux stylos etc a
expliqué que ça pourrait être mieux pour
l'enfant
ce sens mediashare fabien laurenti pause
grâce je trie tout temps s'arrête tout
en sachant que
que ses parents à son retour de vacances
hamel a promis d'aller voir la
diététicienne pour éviter la survenue
d'une hypertension ou d'un diabète
patricia l essayer d'oublier les gâteaux
en écoutant son air de musique favoris
le mondial avec le parcours sans faute
de l'équipe de france hier soir au stade
de vélodrome de marseille
une victoire saluée dans les rues de la
ville par un immense concert de klaxons
les supporteurs à la fête de malgré le
mistral la fierté de tous les bleus ont
réussi leur entrée dans la compétition
et c'était vraiment un beau match
l'équipe de france a levé hier soir
toutes les inquiétudes ou les
appréhensions
l'équipe est battante offensive trois
bus et celui de dugarry qui a fait taire
les contestations au yen la voix andré
germa
il vient de marquer un but en coupe du
monde et regardez le dugarry qui tire la
langue à ses détracteurs comme un grand
gosse surdoué qui se sait mal aimés et
qui d'une pirouette mieux d'un coup de
tête vient de faire se lever un stade
les supporters ont déjà oublié que
jusqu'ici il l'avait rejetée
je connais pas rancunier du tout je sais
pas le faire mais il ya des choses qui
m'ont marqué ya des choses qui m'ont pas
fait plaisir et j'oublie pas quoi qu'il
se passe
dugarry inconstant est contesté depuis
deux ans a toujours gardé la confiance
des médias qu'est contre mistral et
marées pour eux de cet instant est
important dugarry entre en jeu et vous
connaissez la suite
quelques minutes plus tard il libère son
équipe et justifie le choix d'aimer et
je le dois beaucoup je crois qu'on peut
au niveau des critiques
on a été en état pourrait du même niveau
tous les deux donc aux bourses y en a
bien qui m'a soutenu qui m'a fait
confiance et qui a cru en moi c'est bien
lui donc j'avais envie de le rendre de
les rendre cet hommage
l'attaqué de l'équipe de france a donc
retrouvé dugarry elle a marqué trois
buts grâce à la magnifique performance
de thierry henry eux aussi très discuté
ces derniers mois est récompensé par ce
but en fin de match qui a fait perdre un
instant la tête à ce gamin de 20 ans
versatile le public français comme il
est impatient intransigeant ce matin
dugarry et henry étaient à nouveau les
idoles des enfants de provence mais les
mains ne tremble pas pour autant les
têtes sont bien posées sur les épaules
car comme ils disent attaquants échaudé
craint l'eau froide
stéphane guivarc'h blessé hier lors du
match sera sans doute indisponible
pendant dix jours et puis cet après-midi
autre mauvaise nouvelle
david trezeguet s'est lui aussi blessé
lors d'un match amical
il souffre d'une entorse la fête du
football en deuil est aujourd'hui par la
mort de fernand sastre initiateurs de ce
mondial le l'ancien président de la
fédération française de football est
décédé ce matin à l'âge de 74 ans des
suites d'un cancer
l'émotion de michel platini et la minute
de silence pour les 40000 spectateurs du
stade de la beaujoire à nantes
christelle bertrand michel platini a du
mal à retenir ses larmes pendant la
minute de silence à la mémoire de
fernand sastre le complice l'ami de
platini est mort ce matin d'un cancer du
poumon à l'hôpital de la pitié
salpêtrière à paris
monsieur fernand comme tout le monde
l'appelait familièrement avait atteint
la consécration en devenant co président
du comité français d'organisation du
mondial avec michel platini
les deux hommes se connaissaient depuis
longtemps
président de la fédération française de
football de 1973 à 1984
la même année fernand sastre applaudi
michel platini qui vient de gagner le
premier titre de champion d'europe pour
la france fernand sastre est remplacé
par jean fournet-fayard à la tête de la
fédération
en 89 le ministère de la jeunesse et des
sports
mais confie une mission réformer le
football français mais son rêve c'est de
voir la coupe du monde en france le 2
juillet 92 à zurich il dira simplement
on a gagné
pendant six ans fernand sastre s'est
consacré à l'organisation de sa coupe du
monde
le jour de la cérémonie d'ouverture au
stade de france aux côtés de platini la
place de fernand sastre est vide depuis
plusieurs mois la maladie l'empêchait de
travail et fernand sastre meurt à 74 ans
quelques jours après le début de la
coupe du monde de football un football
auquel il aura consacré toute sa vie
grande révélation du dernier mondial le
nigeria battu cet après midi et
l'espagne 3 buts à 2 au stade de la
beaujoire à nantes un match à suspense
et à rebondissements florent gautreau
philippe deslandes
une heure après le match
les tribunes de la beaujoire tremble
encore de plaisir des spectateurs en
france
un gardien qui dansent et se couchent
africaines ont rythmé tout l'après-midi
nantais les espagnols se sont vite mis
au diapason
un départ en fanfare et une tête sur la
barre de raul à c'est le début d'un
match plus à la 20e minute hero
concrétise la domination espagnole
frappe limpide coup franc splendide 1 0
les spectateurs ont à peine le temps de
tourner la tête le corner est pour les
verts tête d'un dépôt joue un partout
même quand l'hiver est rude
les nigérians sont capables de
réchauffer un stade mais juste après la
mi temps raul et ses 20 printemps
refroidissent les ardeurs africaine
l'espagne mène à nouveau au score un peu
de tableaux blancs beaucoup de magie
noire et le match repart dans l'autre
sens
nawal bien servi frappe sans angle les
ou blizzard est à comme l une de ses
erreurs dont il est coutumier le nigeria
égalise à un quart d'heure de la fin
toutes deux joué sentiers motivé pour
buller au monde entier qu'ils jugent
inutiles à el amel et égaler les
champions olympiques et à 12 ans cette
fois en coupe du monde
on doit prouver qu'ils ont foulé aller
loin on pourrait faire mal et ça déjà
c'est mal
cette superbe frappe de scènes d colisée
et tofu au bout d'un match exceptionnel
le nigeria l'emportant 3-2 ce match est
un avertissement pour la france
nous avons aujourd'hui que des équipes
les plus brillantes du mondial et c'est
lui alors et à lyon le mexique a battu
la corée du sud 3 buts à 1 je vous
propose maintenant de revenir la
disparition d'eric tabarly au large du
pays de galles vous le savez le
navigateur est tombé à la mer un peu
après minuit il n'y a pratiquement plus
d'espoir de le retrouver vivant le
gouvernement français demande que les
recherches se soient poursuivies
reportage de notre correspondant à
londres qui tiennent leenhardt
il est 18 heures en fin d'après-midi le
pen duick premier d'eric tabarly entre
dans le port de milford haven escorté
par un bateau des garde-côtes qu'ils ont
récupérés en haute mer
à son bord les quatre équipiers du
navigateur français trois hommes et une
femme qui n'avait eu semble-t-il que
très peu d'expérience de la mer eric
tabarly est tombé du bateau vers minuit
la nuit dernière et ce n'est que tôt ce
matin que les passagers du pain de huit
ont donné l alerte
nous avons été alertés à 7 heures ce
matin par un voilier de plaisance qui
avaient repéré une fusée de détresse
mais ça faisait plus de sept heures
qu'eric tabarly était tombé dans la mer
toute la journée les hélicoptère du
centre de sauvetage de milford haven
vont patrouiller dans la zone mais avec
les heures qui passent l'espoir
s'amenuise rapidement eric tabarly ne
portait pas de bouée de sauvetage
évidemment on peut considérer que
l'expérience demeure tabarly compenser
l'inexpérience de ses passagers mais
avec un accident comme celui-là
ils n'ont pas su comment diriger le
bateau
retrouvez eric tabarly une fois qu'ils
étaient passés par dessus bord
personne n'a pu diriger le bateau et ça
c'est vraiment malheureux ce soir compte
tenu du caractère exceptionnel de la
situation les sauveteurs ont
accepté de poursuivre les recherche avec
deux hélicoptère mais sans grand espoir
et puis pour refermer ce journal je vous
propose ces images du grand large eric
tabarly amoureux de la mère à la barre
de cp nuit qui ont accompagné toute sa
carrière de navigateur hervé brusini le
voilà le secret de tabarly il est
toussaint tenir la barre avec le plaisir
du vernis du texte du cuivre dévoile le
plaisir du paradoxe respecter le rythme
de la mer mais en allant toujours plus
vive aimer la solitude parce qu'on la
trouve reposantes mais avec le souci
permanent des autres quand il vous
accompagne dans les manoeuvres un peu ce
cadre on a toujours peur que quelqu'un
se blesse quelqu'un passe par dessus
bord
sa soeur pour le skipper ce sont des
soucis constants tandis que quand on est
tout seul mon cerveau casse est pour lui
une prenait guère de précaution allez il
est temps de réparer le gréement tabarly
a mis sa musique favorite les copains
ont préparé une fête
le faux dur adore se marrer le faux
taciturne m à gamberger avec les potes
dans le car et non pas par une
choucroute
dehors il fait 50 degrés à l'ombre tous
les plus grands navigateurs l'on tue
pour compagnon
une ville de garde d'ailleurs ils vous
le diront tous tabarly c'est un as pour
pousser la chansonnette
il a du style et de la glace ainsi se
termine ce journal dans un instant la
météo leur en remet chevaux demain midi
polémique
michele cotta aura pour invité françois
hollande je vous remercie de votre
attention
excellente fin de soirée sur france 2